منذ سنوات يعاني مرضى الايدز في ليبيا من
نقص في الادويه دون ان تعبئ الجهات
المعنيه بتوفيرها رغم المناشدات المتكرره
من قبل المرضى الذين يجدون صعوبه بالغه في
توفير العلاج نظرا لاثمانه الباهظه
متى ترصد ميزانيه الطوارئ اللي نقوله بشكل
عام في وزاره الصحه
الادويه الخاصه بالعلاج الفيروس في نهايه
القائمه لانهويه مش عارفين ان يعني هي من
الادويه المهمه جدا ولي تعتبر اولويه اللي
عده نقاط ممكن تبقى يعني وقت نوضها يعني
المتعيشون مع الايدز لا يجدون وظائف
يعملون بها
فالقطاع الخاص والعام يرفضان توظيفهم
اضافه الى انهم يعانون من الوصم والتمييز
المجتمعي
اكون يعني حاجه
يعني
خلال السنوات
كبيره لكن في نسبه بقدر
لكن النسبه الحاليه خلال سنوات
لا يستطيعون العلاج في المستشفيات العامه
فقط في بعض المستشفيات الخاصه
وباثمان المضاعفه